-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for tuning in.
Thank you for watching.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys,
as if President Biden
isn't dealing with
enough right now, tomorrow,
he will deliver his first
State of the Union address.
What timing.
It's like having
your wedding during
a hurricane, an earthquake,
and a sharknado, you know?
The good news is
tough to come by,
so half of Biden's speech
is about how he
finally made
alcoholic Mountain Dew.
Yep, Biden's been going
through a tough time,
so in order to gain support,
just for tomorrow,
he's changing
his last name to Zelensky.
That's right -- as
conflict continues in Ukraine,
the world has been awestruck
by the heroics of
President Zelensky,
who has stayed in Kiev
and vowed to
fight for his country.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah. Sure.
The only way someone could be
more popular is if
Ted Lasso became Spider-Man.
That's the only way.
The U.S. even offered
to evacuate him,
and he said,
"I need ammunition, not a ride."
Yeah, that line is --
[ Applause ]
That line is so good,
Vin Diesel is stealing it
for the next "Fast & Furious."
Meanwhile, I read that a growing
number of U.S. officials
and their allies are questioning
Putin's mental state.
Yeah, Putin poisons his enemies'
underpants for a living,
and now people are concerned?
Today, to show he's still sharp,
Putin was like,
"Person, woman,
man, Smirnoff, borscht.
Person, woman, man,
Smirnoff, bor--"
Speaking of Putin,
I saw that he just met with
his top advisers, but take a
look at the seating arrangement.
This is a real photo.
Wow.
That table is
from Pottery Barn's
Germophobe collection.
Yeah.
That looks like how you seat
your unvaccinated uncle
at Thanksgiving.
Can I see the table again?
Oh, my God.
When they pass the memo
down the table,
the entire Russian curling team
has to come out.
You go...
Of course,
everyone is concerned about
the situation in Ukraine.
And here in the U.S.,
people have started
boycotting Russian vodka.
Yeah, Americans said,
"Look, if we have to rip
tequila shots
until this is over,
then, by God, we will do it."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Just do it.
But thanks to
harsh sanctions from countries
all around the world,
Russia's economy
is spiraling towards
a total collapse.
Here's how bad things
have gotten.
The ruble is now worth
one Chuck E. Cheese token.
Yeah, almost everyone is
coming out against Russia.
Today, even Switzerland --
Switzerland --
broke their neutral status and
froze Putin's assets.
Right now, the Swiss Army
is like, "Attack formation!
Knife! Corkscrew!
Weird, tiny scissors!"
Well, let's change gears.
A new study found that people
will pay more attention to
ads if they feature
dogs and cats.
I guess companies
heard about this study,
which explains this new ad
I just saw.
Check this out.
♪♪
-Our company is dedicated
to making sure
you're always satisfied.
Whatever it takes to
ensure you're happy,
we'll get the job done.
You can count on it.
Better ingredients.
Better pizza.
Papa John's.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
Did you guys see this
or hear about this?
A man in New York just won
$10 million -- $10 million --
from a scratch-off
lottery ticket.
But here's the unbelievable
part -- not just that.
The same man won
$10 million from
another scratch-off ticket
three years ago.
That's insane.
Even crazier,
the same guy was behind him
in line at 7-Eleven both times.
Like, "Oh, come on!"
And, finally,
a woman in Maryland
lost her iPhone 10 years ago,
and her husband just plunged it
out of their toilet.
It was incredible.
He found her phone
and some classified documents
Trump flushed down there.
Yep, after recovering
the iPhone,
they turned it on,
and Siri said...
-Oh, man, I have
seen some [bleep]
-We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots,
ladies and gentlemen!
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, everyone,
before we get started,
obviously, our heart goes out to
everyone in Ukraine right now.
There are families struggling
to figure out what to do,
and they could really
use our help.
If you would like to donate,
you can go to
unicefusa.org/tonightshow.
Anything you can give
will make a difference.
Thank you very much.